good afternoon I'm Philip Khoury I'm
associate provost with the
responsibility for the Arts here at MIT
and I want to welcome you to the public
presentation by Olafur Eliasson of the
2014 Eugene McDermott award in the arts
at MIT we look forward to a stimulating
presentation about the wide range of the
remarkable artists work the title of his
presentation is intriguing to say the
least
holding hands with the son now before
introducing Olaf er let me extend a
special greeting to mrs. Margaret
McDermott she's a dear friend
she is a dear friend extraordinary
benefactor a very special guest who
traveled all the way from her home in
Dallas to be with us on this the 40th
anniversary of the Eugene McDermott
award
I had the enormous privilege of visiting
with Margaret in Dallas just a few weeks
ago where she is the city's leading
patron of the Arts her hospitality
incidentally is second to none
accompanying Margaret on this visit is
her daughter Mary McDermott cook who is
with us right here delighted you're here
narrator among her many activities in
Dallas and beyond she's president of the
Eugene McDermott foundation we're
thrilled really to have you both of you
returned here back to MIT you honor us
by being here let me say a few words
about the McDermott award and what the
McDermott family has done for MIT
established in 1974 by Margaret
McDermott to honor her late husband
Eugene co-founder of Texas Instruments
the McDermott award recognizes
individuals whose artistic trajectory
and body of work indicate that they will
achieve the highest distinction in their
fields the award is considered an
investment in the recipients future
creative work rather than a prize for a
particular project or a lifetime of
achievement a special feature of the
award is the campus residency and an
important focus one that mrs. McDermott
herself has encouraged that is the
direct interaction with students a goal
that has been realized in exemplary ways
in this residency most of all the
McDermott award reflects mi t--'s
commitment to risk-taking
problem-solving and connecting creative
minds across disciplines I just want to
add the McDermott family have been major
contributors to mi t--'s top-ranked
public art collection and the McDermott
scholarship endowment fund has supported
more MIT undergraduates than any others
any such fund at MIT it really is a
tribute to this family
and their support to us now permit me to
recount just a few aspects of oleifera
lessons work some of which of course you
just witnessed I believe you'll
understand why he's such an ideal
recipient of the McDermott award his
extraordinary body of work and comes as
a broad range of creative practices
spanning art science and psychology he
has made strikingly original
contributions to public art to
architecture and recently to social
entrepreneurship his installation the
weather project which we just saw a bit
of was visited by more than 2 million
people for this project he installed an
immense artificial Sun in London's Tate
Modern transforming that cavern
cavernous turbine Hall with ethereal
light and fog and producing a completely
unique immersive environment through
such phenomenological investigations of
light color atmosphere and water he has
probed the nature of space and of human
perception oleifera liason is probably
best known in this country for two
exhibitions one is take your time
oliver elias it was a survey exhibition
organised in 2007 by the san francisco
museum of art which traveled until 2010
stopping in New York at MoMA and at the
Dallas Museum of Art the other is New
York City waterfalls commissioned by the
public art fund in 2008 with support of
then Mayor Michael Bloomberg it's a
series of four man-made waterfalls in
the East River in New York most recently
our McDermott honoree collaborated with
engineer Frederic Utterson who was with
us this evening to develop little son
which you saw in the video a portable
solar powered LED lamp for the 1.6
billion people worldwide without access
to electricity which he calls a work of
art that works in life you will
understand why Oliver Elias ins work
resonates with the creative values of
the MIT community we particularly admire
the wide-ranging and ambition nature of
his creative practice which spans
multiple domains without regard for
disciplinary boundaries we admire the
collaborative enterprise that
his creative output we admire his
relentless experimentation with light
space movement and the nature of human
perception which compels audiences to
engage with their environment and with
one another and we admire his confidence
that art makes a difference in this
world of ours we look forward now to
hearing from Olafur Eliasson our 2014
McDermott Award recipient Oliver please
come up in a round of applause
thank you so much it's a long intro hard
to follow lot has been said already
Thank You Marco for having me you look
so great today now it's a very exciting
to be here I have in fact been here
already for it's now the second day and
this is my fourth lecture in so I'm sort
of warmed up and it's been a big
experience to enjoy the hospitality of
MIT sort of hopping through the
departments and seeing all the
incredible sort of the mass of research
going on and the degree of criticality
and self criticality so that of course
aver is very inspiring I have you have
had a very sort of now I have so much
stuff in my head so I hope I can to some
extent at least talk a little bit about
the works that I brought on my computer
because I have a lot of new ideas now
but let me start by talking a little bit
about the project that was briefly
mentioned if this it is ten years old as
of this winter and it was a project
which to me meant a sort of a strong
increase in the confidence of the
potential of what creativity can
actually do and it also brought me to
this idea that well maybe it's to some
extent about art but maybe it's really
about people and I'm confident that the
systems in which art work the museums
and galleries and so on and so forth but
also the wider systems the general
confidence in creativity in art in
culture in the greater society I'm sure
that art has something to offer which as
a kind of a model of how we respect each
other how we share things how we discuss
with each other I'd has something there
which i think is highly valuable so I
become increasingly involved with
working against the marginalization of
art and culture in political systems in
this
xiety systems the idea of what is civic
society how it is structured and so on
the reason why this is a project here
the tape model was important for me was
that it for me showed a space in which
people came in and the Turbine Hall in
London it's an old power station the
south south of the Thames and the
project opened and it was first shown at
the weather forecast in the news as we
know Brits in England everybody loves
that I would like here so that lover
loves the weather and the weather it's
interesting because besides being the
the nature or the bit of nature we have
in cities it rains this is like the
nature kind of entering culture if you
want but the weather is all sort of a
space where we can actually have a
different experience of the weather I
really hate when it rains and the person
next to me says I really love when it
rains and I still like that other person
I said oh we can be together so so
interestingly a museum or platform on
which one can have art is is to some
extent a success with regards to
facilitating this ability to disagree
and sharing at the same time so you can
be singular this is this is my view on
the world and you can at the same time
be plural this is you know I need to
share the world disregarding that I
disagree and as we look at the greatest
society we of course concede a lot of I
should say like polarization exclusion
or you do if you disagree you're not
welcome if you're different you're not
welcome if you're not you know kind of
synchronised synchronizing with me I'm
actually not going to work with you so
in this case and and I think there's
something about art here it was a space
where there was a highly singular or
highly personal experience people they
looked and they sort of started behaving
differently than they do it seems
normally as you can see they laid down
on the floor they stayed longer they
kind of brought in their picnics they
pick knees on the floor and they sort of
spend time and use the machine in
different ways I would say it also
became a public space it was almost like
the city took a part of the museum to
its heart the idea of public
something where you can have both shared
experiences and individual experiences
became no possible I like this idea of
being singular and plural at the same
time I think there's something very
democratic about it something about
sharing values and also respecting the
individual needs see this is a small
film let me see if I can turn it on so
people are as you can tell laying on the
floor the distance to the ceiling is
roughly 30 meters because looking up to
the ceiling 30 meters is something but
you're sort of looking down again with
30 meters down again so that means
you're looking 60 meters and finding
yourself at a distance of 60 meters is
exciting because you cannot help seeing
yourself in the context of the space
you're not just looking for yourself you
are in fact also seeing yourself in the
let's say in the greater system of of
this space there's a hard to focus on
top and as I listen to me at the same
time I could say a lot about this
project because also I think it's
important to see that looking at a work
of art almost as a mmm I would say
machine but you know as a fin anima Krim
creator in which the performance of the
audience audience of the user or the
spectator becomes the vehicle for that
work is an interesting idea I think I
worked always like let's see if we can
hand over a great degree of the
responsibility of making the ad work to
the people who actually use it as user
sort of pragmatic and it's lovely
demystifying but use in the sense that
you make an effort you come into the
museum and you engage you might immerse
yourself you engage in in terms of you
go look for something when you look at a
work of art you start you start a a
journey in which your effort is
requested so it's not like consuming
it's not like sitting in a Hollywood
sort of moving just kind of all taking
it all in doing nothing right you have
to work a little bit you have to kind of
give a little bit of yourself
if the artwork is successful I think
that it actually succeeds in how should
I say verbalizing something bringing
language to something which you already
feel you kind of have it in yourself but
you haven't quite vocal eyes did
yourself yet right so you go and you
look for something and what you're
looking at is actually yourself and of
course this can then be debated and so
on and so forth but generally speaking a
great work of art somehow brings to
length with something that you already
know but you haven't quite figured out
how to say it it's very interesting it's
almost like riff it reflects you so in
that sense it's a little bit
I wouldn't say therapy but I just don't
it's a little bit late you go and you
make an effort and sometimes the effort
to understand something is more
important than the understanding itself
the effort or the process of the time it
takes for you to kind of get involved
and this is why this is such an exciting
little field the time it takes for you
to get involved is as valuable as the
time for you to kind of say okay now I
got it and I can go home see there is
not so many spaces in the world that
facilitates that type of activity we
have academia we have great academic
sort of methodology and we have places
like MIT where people exercise the
questions and the critique of the
questions as an integral part of the
questions right so there and of course
structural thing is to actually is my
postmodern thinking brought a lot of new
tools to the toolbox in which I was
educated at the times the early 90s and
so on and so forth this is one of my
very first pieces it's a it's a rainbow
at the lack of a better photo it's just
drizzling water and a little spotlight
and as we know a rainbow takes a little
more than the spotlight and the
drizzling water takes it also needs the
eye so you have the iron mm-hmm this one
it's funny the is actually it's like a
little machine right you can act you can
even see that I do you know this
experiment probably somebody from MIT
came up with that that experiment if you
press the eyeball you can sort of see
how the image so there's a little sort
of spherical thing in your head anyway
I drop light that makes a rainbow so if
I stand here I see one rainbow but my
friend Oh
here right she's another rental so we
can kind of agree okay this is a rainbow
but it's not the same rainbow it's two
different rainbows and this is so so so
so removing the traditional add object
this is 93 making space for the subject
or the spectator in this case suggesting
that the producing the I component is a
part of that work was almost suggesting
well maybe the artist maybe the
biographical sort of material is less
important maybe the biographical
material of the spectator the working
spectator the producing spectator the
co-author is the protagonist this became
the beginning of investigating public
space different spaces architecture and
this is a project this is in Sweden this
is the Parliament in Sweden the
Parliament sort of on the island this is
called strong it's a lovely very clean
water storm the Swedes they love their
clean water coming straight up in going
into the ocean and with a little bit of
non-toxic dye normally used dye normally
used for tracking ocean currents you
could with an instant you can kind of
dye a whole river green and a number of
artists has been played with these
things and what I think is interesting
here is that this city as such is of
course when we think about is something
organic like it's the life between
buildings that makes up a city
well sometimes heaven is that the city
is so sets of self obsessed with its own
image that it kind of leans towards
something more static we see a lot of
cities in Europe that are to some extent
at least turning into museums now this
is a debate within urbanistic planning
and to what extent does BD cities
actually represent the values of the
societies in which they are or are they
becoming so let's say monuments of
certain times where other values was
guided so the idea of sort of
recalibrating the depth of the space
with regards to its hospitality I
thought I could just toss a little bit
of color into a river like that and kind
of with a almost like a shock effect
suggest well this space is in fact
organic it moves it passes by time is
very important if you have time
you also have activity if you have
activity there's more space for people
so in the great tradition of you know
very typically yes as a Scandinavian
investigative mythology of how to
generate public space this was I think a
project that I did again and again and
with some success next day the police in
Sweden wrote in the paper that a lot of
people have called into the police and
asked why on earth are they real and the
police had come down people saying that
the Parliament actually had a leak in
the heating system this is a Swedish way
sort of of keeping keeping people calm
but so the idea of making things
explicit at the Green River making it
explicit is also having confident in
confidence in the physicality of it
instead of looking at a picture actually
engaging in the let's say the water and
the things that are hard to understand
such such as time passing of time it's
like it bit abstract the one of the
great questions today is like everybody
knows what a glacier is because some
people even have been on a glacier but
everybody also knows so so we have the
climate crisis and we have the general
question about how to understand what
you know ice is what the climate is and
what the ephemera sort of is the
changing of climate I'm a part of a
generation where when I was a child the
climate wasn't natural right so it was
considered okay here I'm in culture and
over there's nature it's interesting and
and I was you know when I grow up I
hiked a lot with my my father and you
know so I went a lot too at lacers and
so on but as I grew older I realized
well the climate is not natural the
climate is in fact cultured it is you
know to some extent and increasingly
accepted like no man made a woman made
and the thing here is I think the the
thing is the challenge laced with how do
we make things explicit explicit from
theoretical knowledge to physical
knowledge of course that's an old that's
an old story within art and you know if
you have an idea here
no I have an idea for work of art it's
still not a work of art until I've done
it the journey between thinking and
doing as we know can be very wise and
there's a lot of steps in there where
you are sort of working as a mechanical
engineer if you want the same thing
right thinking doing and these steps I
think are very important when I've been
here at MIT sort of an on a side note it
is all about bringing thinking and do it
together bridging that gap so in this
case I thought well people in Berlin
here can't go to Iceland so I just I'll
just bring the glacier to Berlin so I
froze down a space take minus 10 degrees
and the blood the Glacial blocks of the
Batna you could they drops off to the
grater as it sort of falls into the
ocean and I could pick it up with a
tractor on the beat and just ship it in
a fiscally frozen fish container to
Berlin very easy actually and then I
showed them as you can tell it's so
beautiful the ice itself and what is
maybe more important is that you can
actually touch it and it's incredible
and you touch the code I was really cold
so funny and and there's something here
which is very censored because it's
about bringing our you knew it was
caused no surprise but yet when you
touch it it is different than what from
what you knew this is very important the
kind of idea of bringing knowledge
knowledge and action together simply by
touching so there so the title here
holding hands with the Sun you can see
where this is going so let me just show
you this now I have to fire you hmm so
this is a it's gonna be a little doubt
so or maybe not let me just say
something before I started because you
can yeah I could tell before you didn't
listen when I was attorney so basically
ice flow very big I thought totally
known this is in Sao Paulo it said this
apple pie nu quite a while ago so
interestingly everybody like everybody
is as I said know about ice is very easy
from a distance already oh
it's ice and then you sort of oh
interesting then you start running I
think so very disruptive to the
exhibition again so people running
through the exhibition the and and
they're kind of being loud and so on and
have a look at at this you see how I
like is it going
thank you sir
and starting argument or excuse
disregarding that you know very well
so this is an opening cell power
let's say concessions
it was just too much sudden didn't it
didn't fit the canopy babe
I don't concede that ice continued
didn't want to pay
fantastically Niemeyer building this
idea of you know the social boundaries
so I don't mean to by all means there is
not so much Isis or power and if I don't
mean it you know there's so much other
stuff so it's not really about that but
listen the thing is that the discrepancy
between knowledge the physical knowledge
became very clear here because some
people actually sat down and the eyes
are almost nice and key here to this
hospice and the fact the the nice thing
was they said oh my god the ice is
melting when you sit on it but so they
knew perfectly well what it was
me being this is silly flurry you do
know my home this is the curator being a
little bit concerning ad adrionna
Pedroza but let me see if I can so these
sort of interventions investigating the
boundaries of of where do our you know
how far does our tolerance our
hospitality our sense of space go with
regards to can we actually exercise the
idea of diversity we have because we
have such great thoughts about how
resourceful we are with regards to
hospitality right so we think of course
a way you could do anything if you want
in this museum you can have any type of
exhibition everyone as long as it's not
noisy of course and so on and so forth
so so again even our values the values
we carry with us through society
sometimes we think oh if somebody falls
over on a bike of course I would go over
and help the person like get up but then
you're on the street and somebody falls
oh my god this person is drunk can I
help
I am I gonna get into so all these sort
of boundaries between you know what and
how do you act in public space right
it's very complex and of course we would
want a public space that actually
facilitates the trust in this way but
the truth is that's not always the case
what type of space what type of
architecture what type of pavement
actually facilitates the values that we
think or we have but we don't know
actually how to bring into doing this is
a project this is Johannesburg it's also
in the 90s I emptied out a small rain
water reservoir to kind of create the
little river that I called the ocean
wersal in action I was invited for
biennial had a nice little photo piece
about Scandinavia and I was walking
walking around in downtown derelict
Johannesburg at the time 96 I think it
was a Korean visa what's the curator I
said oh my god this is so typically Here
I am all the way from Berlin at the time
in two hands Berg my god I have to do
something different than just showing a
photo of the photo of Iceland you know
by all means so I said oh look at this
incredible rainwater so why why don't I
go rent a little diesel pump and empty
it out on the street and see if I can
make a river
and and of course the curator I didn't
ask him for sure of course because I
sort of yes interesting time so 96 to
Harrisburg downtown derelicts squatted
buildings you know the time angle
American you know the anglo-saxon Bank
the diamond stock exchange the diamond
building and in like very complex very
complex area and I thought the idea of
erosion time River like a poem like a
little river that just comes and goes
was very beautiful is rainwater so it
wasn't really that rains enough for
collecting the wasn't using it for
public public what irrigation and this
is the river it's all more about as you
can tell it ran roughly a mile and a
half through sort of organized and
unorganized areas and it ended up in the
sort of in the in the sewer this is in
Los Angeles
lots of Sun morning so midday late
afternoon and if you walk in you can
actually see that the light is moving
it's very beautiful very good for LA so
stand there it go like mmm and then you
go and then you go then it's like
interesting there's nothing there and
suddenly your own presence become
becomes quite explicit and yourself so
so it's interesting before the light was
over there and now it's here suddenly
there's that kind of cosmic connection
I won't overdo that but it's interesting
because it actually does change a lot
have you been on the street watching how
the poll of you know the shadow of a
street lamp it actually moves like very
fast and that is the speech speed with
which the planet travels through space
around the Sun obviously as as we have
come to learn the Sun actually doesn't
move it's the earth that goes around so
what you can see is in fact you're
travelling and it's time travel so to
some extent there's it's the time it
takes so there's a lot of stuff in here
and I think what we are you know what we
are I guess to some extent with regards
to being abstract you know making things
explicit
also has to do with do we actually
succeed to see the planet or they serve
the idea of the planet as one thing how
do we identify with the planet as one
object so I've been very interested in
the sort of questions from cosmology or
deep-space cosmology how do you
understand the planet in the context of
the universe now this gets a little
abstract but the the point here is I
think one of the greater challenges with
regards to for instance that climate
crisis we spoke about that the climate
crisis is that it does require that you
kind of think of the planet as an object
sort of does you don't you do need to
sort of think of everything at the same
time which is very difficult because
difficult enough to even understand
America is one sort of ecosystem to see
the whole thing and this idea of
interdependence collectivity the global
search idea of sharing of sharing
responsibility
how does responsibility feel it's very
difficult so in that and of course
that's a far stretch to say as part of
light on the floor and then
responsibility it's a bit but still I
think you know if one can actually think
of yourself in the context of something
planetary if you want you think of
Kepler and the work he did so and that
that was so groundbreaking anyway so not
that this is quite on the scale of
Kepler but but there I would like to I
would like to toss this work about in
the kind of trajectory or the orbit of
Kepler Kepler kind of thinking same
question Glacier glacier melting River
running aerial photography and somewhere
in the middle roughly here three rows up
there is a damping field this is a water
you can hydro electric power damping
built in Iceland so this means the lower
no the upper half I mean everything on
the left side and up from that dam is
now underwater is almost a mine a mile
deep on the on the deepest part 800
meters there's not quite a mile but but
but it's very deep at the deep and then
everything else
on the right side is still yeah so this
is a little documentary of a space that
was which is now underwater
and of course the whole question of damn
hydrogenic electricity the company from
America who built who's running this to
melt aluminium I serve a lot of debates
its Alcoa
so it's a complex photo a documenting
something you know a black a black river
on a snowy white landscape so almost
like a Japanese calligraphic poem
Chinese if you want so I have a handful
of works like this I thought I will just
walk you through them and there's not a
lot left and then we have roughly half
an hour for some questions see I mean I
always wonder whether I should talking
long for a few works or less for a lot
of work so now I'm kind of in-between I
hope it's okay I hope it's okay for you
this is the water for this project that
I was lucky to do in New York together
with the mayor's office a lot of people
came together and supported this project
one of the main supporters egging who's
here tonight it's great to see you Aggie
there what's a force I thought for me
was about claiming space taking space
simply I know from Iceland when I'm in
front of a landscape and I look at the
landscape and I always get so excited
because there's nothing in the landscape
that kind of indicates the size of the
scale the depth and you look at it
there's no trees you almost cannot even
see the wind because there's no grass
blowing there's no no the things that
normally indicates depth distance height
are gone it's like being on the moon and
you go like one way of making dimensions
is by walking as I start walking and the
two mountains in front of me one comes
closer very fast and one stays under
horizon that means oh the two mountains
that I thought was roughly the same side
actually the one is a small mountain
close by and the other was a big man far
away so by walking I can create a sense
of scale right not just out there and
the landscape arose in my body if I
don't walk and I stop and I look around
it's hard for me to understand again the
scale but then there is a waterfall I
look at the waterfall and I go and I see
the water it
very slowly and I said oh it's a high
waterfall
I put ass water falls roughly with the
same speed and and suddenly I realized
the waterfall is also a sort of temporal
indicator it gives space not just the
time but it also gives you the depth I
can by looking at the waterfall see how
long time it takes me to walk there I
can measure the distance from here to
the waterfall and the height simply by
looking at it's very interesting I was
sitting in the Semien Mountains and the
northern end of it seopressor of looking
into south of Sudan and the amazing
landscape is on the roof of the roof of
Africa is also called the Simien
mountains and you can have your legs off
the cliff like this and there's a drop
of a mile approximately a kilometer so
it's amazing winds the birds are coming
up from like and you sit down you just
see the Sun and totally amazing like and
and I go like wow look at look I wonder
how far away do you know these small
mountains down there is and this is how
bin I think it's like in 3,000 meters
height
what is that 10,000 feet so so and then
I call and then I look down the rim and
I see oh there's a waterfall over and
then the water falls so slow it's really
deep and I take my legs in you know so
so so it's it's very interesting what
water can do to space so now look at
public space look at the American public
space the history of public space John
Dewey the work that has been made into
making space the place in which we meet
and share and exchange and the public
space has a rich history there's
different versions there's the East
Coast West Coast different ideas in New
York and and LA I saw lots of material
rights then there's Europe the idea of
Europe southern Europe nor Europe is
assuming so the Italian public space the
kind of meeting up type of space and the
Northern European as well something
which I find very interesting as a space
with this to a great extent there to
facilitate and reflect the values that
we have in our society right and to to
the extent that this is a success we can
debate because of course what happens is
that public space is to a great extent
privatized it is full of intentionality
structures power structures political
structures and so on where we think of
it as being public meaning free but it
is in fact not free
what do we do to claim it back so the
water forceful for me was about
suggesting ephemeral temporal sort of
experiential materials like qualities
indicating that this space actually has
depth especially the highlight no they
they sort of skyline in New York was the
greatest skyline but you also kind of
look at it it is exactly like a postcard
it's a little bit like what I said about
stuck on in the beginning we have to
make sure that a space allows for the
people to be in it sometimes a space can
be so self-obsessed with its own
rendering that it is only happy when
rendered we need to allow space to have
enough space for people to meet and you
need a little space to meet like 100
meters 50 meter 20 meter then at 50
meters oh it's a man a woman 20 meter
you can see whether they're smiling 10
meter you can tell oh better I so move
out I should go to the person that space
is important this is the space in which
we build trust in each other if you
don't have that space and if there's
always kind of a you know a store
reaching out hey cube we want your
attention if we don't have enough space
for us to sort of also see how do I feel
do I feel okay does the space actually
support my idea of going over to the
person failed on the bike and helping
the person others to the space they
don't just get you know just put on your
walkman and just go just go on so I'm
very interested in these things so the
resources besides me being obsessed
about Iceland and waterfalls and all
that's thing I think this is a so for me
it was about that and you know asking
these questions this is in Denmark
museum art museum and I proposed them to
put a rainbow on the roof like a
permanent rainbow so that idea is still
around
do you remember and here you have a
rainbow if you stand in one place and
just do nothing nothing changes you
stand in the red area
everything's just red which is not not
so bad also but if you walk which is
also if you if you work then things
happens if you walk around the color
changes this means that they were
walking
self is what creates here the work of
art what people do is that they come up
here is it's it's a lovely walk because
you kind of go through all the colors
and it's as you can tell really a very
basic idea and and and a lot of things
happens because the museum of course got
very excited because a lot of people
who'd normally did not come to the
museum suddenly started going to the
museum saying wow this is a heart it is
also about looking at the world it is
about the perspective of looking right
so talk about listen is when suddenly
the museum downstairs the distance
between the two paintings became very
interesting you look at a painting great
monk painting they have amazing monk
paintings I think for maybe the distance
from one monk painting to the next it's
also interesting the time it takes for
you to digest the narrative you just
took in and how that produces the next
so the sequence of the temporal aspects
of a museum is of course where the
potential is it's not like I looked at a
moon painting and then I'm off general
solo then BOOM again I look at the moon
painting the the success of a museum is
of course the kind of temporal narrative
that people take with them home we don't
remember moments we remember pieces of
time the concert house so so until I got
more involved with architecture
crystalline structures mathematical
systems this is a quasi crystalline
Pentagon a principle brought into a kind
of all space feeling principles our
space feeling is when you stack stuff
without any cracks between them so I
some time ago I was lucky to have an
engineer oh so I think of out who comes
out of visionary mathematics in my
studio IQ pied him fall for a while and
and he was obsessed with all space
feeling mathematical principles
stackable everything was stackable this
as you can see is a stackable facade but
crystalline and acrylic glass and heat
and terms are also also a few questions
of climate and I said insulation and
technical solutions what is maybe most
interesting is what you see here because
when you if you're into so
for such structures and you know a big
steel facade like that then you would
know well normally there would be a
column holding it but as you can tell it
just stands out by itself this means
it's a self carrying structure and so
there is a bit of engineering a bit of
science if you want into making this
actually aesthetically active so that's
a feel that I've been quite interested
in so it's not an existing building on
which I apply a work of art as as kind
of decorating painting on something
already there it is a part of the
building structure so when the architect
asked me to get involved because they
needed to win the competition I said
okay but I want to do something that
I've actually holds up the building I
don't want to do something that
decorates the building if I'm not a part
of the building I won't be a part of the
team which of course was not a problem
this is the model my models this is I've
been looking a lot into mathematical and
scientific sort of systems of space
depiction and spatial processes and so
on I won't go into that too much here
the evolution of building this is
actually this is quite a while ago when
the wall in Berlin Cape Town a few years
did pass by before the walls of Albania
came down I was very interested in
Albania when it came down because
Albania was so closed and the city of
Tirana
was just in in the center of Europe but
it had not been accessible as we all
know and so on so quite early on after
Albania becoming open there was a number
of architecture competitions in which I
was involved and the mayor ad Rama of
Tirana
invited me to be on a sort of advisory
board for City Planning and I was not so
long after I was not involved anymore
but the point the point here is that I I
started looking into well how do we hand
over the ownership of the space to the
people who were deprived from from
thinking that they could produce space
and and in one of the process was to
let's make a city
out of LEGO bricks and I called Kel cuke
the owner of legal said we need some
legal brings in tirana and he was very
interested because the people had never
played with legal it's very interesting
it says they're almost impossible and
now there's like no one left but so so I
said let's put in a big tape sort of a
table same size as the kind of vs. so
roughly depict in the city and then
let's allow people to go and then build
so so a few things interesting people
started you know territorially thinking
about well should I be oh I should I be
next to this person and the kind of
policeman from the city the the kids
selling secrets out of this kind of you
know walk arrabal sick they were
standing next to each other at some
point the gun from the policeman is like
on the table and the cigarettes of the
kid was on this table and it's very
interesting and and you know not not
that it was like kind of a revolution
anything but there was this kind of
coming together on a project details a
lot of the buildings had the legal brick
the other way around like with it with
it there's brown things going down
because nobody had actually necessarily
built and if you can see they didn't
press them very well together right so
we grow up and and it's a narrow meters
it's not like we and them but by all
means we it's just so interesting that
that the kind of knowledge that we have
in our hands pressing a little bit
together and so on so the so the legal
owner he was actually there standing
there you know looking and he was so
surprised they wouldn't press it to go
he's an engineer so he said I wonder
what people don't write and you're so
interesting seeing seeing him looking at
and so lots of lovely details but really
also about what does it mean to share a
space what does mean you know of course
some people immediately build big wall
and a fence around them but some people
started making bridges and breaking down
the walls
you sort of saw that in the introduction
I won't drag you through that again but
oh no it's going backwards I wonder if I
you saw it before point is so sometimes
in my studio I do these spatial
experiments some of them requires
dancers to bring the body back into my
work then I recorded on film and make a
little work of art of live but the
interesting part is really the idea if
you can walk very slowly and then they
have the kind of slow motion trainer to
come and then we practice in the studio
not that I need people to be slow but
interestingly everything else gets
proportionately fast okay just so I
tried this oh I wonder whether I have a
slide where I am blocking no I don't
okay so anyway I is it there is it
coming if I press here is it after later
okay anyway so it's coming the it's very
difficult to investigate time obviously
time plays a road role in my works oh
this is actually a little film but the
one I think you saw also in the truck
introduction but time being kind of a
co-producer of the works I just go on
I'm sorry
time being a co-producer of the work is
I think very very difficult but very
important because time is so intensive
it is difficult to so control and make
explicit it does take time to build
confidence it does take time to build
self-confidence it takes time to
experience so this means we do in the
studio where I occupy around 90 people
we do make some effort in exercising how
does the passing or the flowing of time
actually feel I should ask you Margaret
by all means the it's just so important
that we don't forget how the experience
builds the moment and turns into
memories so I work a lot with this thing
and I make an effort to bring some
communal let's say projects into the
into the studio where we invite people
to come and eat we have a few lovely
chefs cooking every day and the 90
people is this is the moment where the
three teams in the studio their
architectural teams the craftsman who
works with the hands and they and the
archive the research and archive people
they all meet and they exchange you know
formalities and in formalities and often
we have friends like I said Jesse this
is Rick we're down here in the corner
grabbing sneaking in and by having a
bite the the studio has if you don't
mind me walking down the path of the
studio a little bit the studio has on
the top floor that's the red building
there on the left side it's the studio
on the top upper floor it has a school
it had a school which is closed two
weeks ago where I for five years under
the funding of the science ministry in
Berlin were looking into education and
methodology in in art education you know
I love Molly and a few friends from here
has also been there and we really try to
build a system which was driven by non
curriculum education where we took for
granted something very important that
the students were already created by the
time they made it into the school I
didn't have to teach them to make up I
was there to help them to bring thinking
into doing and also having confidence
with abstraction something that is less
tangible not quantifiable the success
could be in the temporal and not in this
sort of solidification of the idea and
the school brought about it a lot of
experiments so one experiment as you can
see this is a flag kind of flagpole but
the flag itself is a piece of metal when
the wind blowed it was like it was like
thunder I was a lovely student project
so it's like the thundering flag
we took that down to Addis Ababa where I
spent two months with the studio also
teaching and kind of collaborating with
the editors at Addis Ababa University
and a pet department there and the
thundering flag of course meant
something very different in Ethiopia
than it does in Berlin not too different
though
another flag so I start that all the
students the sounds little sounds like
they only do flex but this is like a
giant flag that you sort of walk through
the city well the idea of taking away
their eyes sort of getting a sense of
space and and you know student
experiments with physicality the doing
component was maybe more in focus than
they I wouldn't say we're not thinking
but you know thinking alone for sure
won't make you an artist walking through
the city using a reflected image is it
very difficult but an interesting
exercise because you have to kind of
work a little bit on on the construction
of how you see them suddenly this sudden
you can make new rules motoric you know
frictions so taking away the basic
motoric just making the cutlery like a
meter long it's very difficult to say
but you can also space them the famous
studio learning experiments that we're
trying to train to be a lion we did that
out last night up in the media any lions
from last night here here we were older
but Jeffrey better anyway so we were
it's my fourth lecture as I told you a
lovely lecture last night with the
tickling laughter and the lion
experiment - lion is of course
pretending to be a lion once you start
to pretend to be aligned you realize oh
I could get actually I could actually
get into that I could get very good at
it and to become a lion it is not so
easy but it's also not impossible and
you start with a pole right soon as you
can and it takes the taste like fig we
won't do now but you can sort of it's
called point the pawing exercise is
already in your mind there's a little
space in your brain that start to evolve
how do I make a LAN port so two cushions
or like a lion two cushions this was
nice little four toes on the front
thinking kind of like this you can start
to point exercising if you go through
the whole thing you get lion and then
there's the famous Sphinx down here it's
just it's a French a French I can talk
about is the lion experiment comes out
of the French conceptual dancer
who you might know had very lot of
success in the 90s called savvy Aloha
I'm sorry love I was amazing for
instance conceptual dance who made you
know a lot of physical experiments like
one doesn't dance but turning the studio
into a Savannah so very healthy exercise
see that's a classic lion posture our
slow motion trainer that guy on that
photo I will see I'm coming closer to to
to round this up talking about little
Sun so see see this is our I went to
China outside of Shanghai and they in
the shishun Gardens amazing rock gardens
with amazing architecture and I made a
film about time and space and these are
the gardens that went before the
Japanese gardens the kind of the
ancestor to the Japanese gardens and
they're lovely here it's winter so
there's you know no no leaves very
minimal and stained who is our old
street dancer now a slow-motion
specialist she's about so episode public
again likes the street and the kind of
as you know in China they have all these
round doors and I had these mirrors in
the film and the film is 20 minutes long
so
suggest that one shot or something just
see the next scene here stain is Treeing
see the tree on one side I can that's
really funny I think but anyway so this
is me just bringing tonight so I
actually do to get inspired I sometimes
go out this is the part close to my
studio and then I'm I'm rehearse I'm not
as good as stayin in slow motion but I
go out and I train doing that in public
spaces like also investigating they list
this unless the city of the public space
does the public space really like me
making slow motion in it you know and
look at that look at that lovely woman
there how she looks at me and she goes
that what is this guy doing you know and
and but but the question is the question
is really not her looking at me the
crisis mom how does she feel right does
he feel comfortable or uncomfortable but
just because I'm walking slow motion
does she kind of hold onto her back you
know so so we have to ask ourself the
spaces in which me move what feelings do
they facilitate what type of artistic
intervention would maybe make that
explicit or challenge that even is it a
problem that people move differently
always maybe maybe it's good maybe
diversifying movements it's interesting
do you mind me just skipping that
picture and this one and going to this
one I think I spoke for a while I'll
just grab a little
so a few years from now a father from my
son's class or a guy who has a son in
the same class as my son and I were
talking and turns out he was a solar
engineer
and knew a lot about light and I'm
obsessed with light and the kind of
ephemeral quality of light and you know
the Sun I say as you have seen and and
suddenly we we had to make a long story
short we had this idea of no storing
light storing energy and if you could go
out into the Sun and kind of take some
Sun just like two like this then record
the Sun almost like sample like like a
DJ makes a sample and then you take it
somewhere else and then you say okay now
this is the light I can show you here
this is how the Sun in Berlin looks like
this is sunlight from Berlin we recorded
the light with this one the little
yellow the little black thing here and
I'm playing it here in Boston so it's
very interesting the light from Berlin
travelled I said the ephemeral quality
of the light from Berlin travelled with
me on the plane and came to Boston and
of course what that means is that I have
a little power station I have access to
power in terms of decentralized power I
have my own power station I am my own
power station I can choose to have
energy that is mine I charge not just
the power stays in I charge myself so
it's very interesting with regards to do
I feel resourceful or not to the space
in which I am allow me to feel
resourceful what type of space I might
maybe the power in the space I am it's
highly they say centralized maybe it's
maybe I have to support the oil industry
so maybe the power is really not the
power I want maybe I want this power
instead if I'm a child who grows up
reading my bedtime stories with this
light from 6 and so on maybe I'm more
likely once I have to make a choice for
energy in my house when I grow maybe I'm
more likely to have confident
in solar energy final Ternes of energy
resources there's so much material in
this which is about so many things
frederik arts isn't the engineer sitting
over here you should talk to him because
he is really it's really very MIT if you
want the the confidence in this was to a
great extent inspired by the
collaboration between engineering and
creativity they need of course is to
raise the question the awareness the
policy-making about what does it mean to
have access to energy and who have that
responsibility and we very quickly came
to the conclusion where this has to work
for everybody
it is not about off-grid it's about
every grid as both often off on grid of
course this story about the climate that
I was talking about suddenly you have a
little thing here that makes you know
something a little bit explicit let's
just say it's a foot in the door in
understanding what on earth is energy it
just normally just comes out of a block
somewhere and then you just take it and
we sometimes make the mistake we take
the energy for granted as if it was just
like kind of in abundance to understand
that energy you have to go out you have
to collect it and to make to have a
little power station sort of teaches you
just like when when what I thought this
when we got a little first steam machine
like how amazing is that little thing
with a toilet where water and then some
a little wheel turns and then you have
energy like boiling the water so this is
the kind of same thing of course we then
went specifically to address the need
for energy in certain groups we're
looking now at rural parts of the world
where there's no energy access such as
Africa we have worked for two years
we're on the ground in Africa and eight
countries we're selling them through
different sort of private market driven
NGO driven also with a market component
it's not an aid project and some
governments are totally not successful
working with governments is impossible
but you know the other people this is a
great success in terms of we as we are
seeing fantastic sales in the world
where there is a leader who is energy at
a higher price twenty thirty dollars
actually MoMA in New York is next week
launching their spring catalog where
this is on the car
so there were a lot of lamps and so on
and so forth we're selling them here in
Boston also we have self started selling
them on museums and on lines and design
stores and so on with that profit we
deliver the lamps in outlets which also
sells them to build local economies
micro economies sort of street vendor
economies informal economies and by
doing so we hope to create sort of
enough profit at the sort of end of the
vertical to the last mile in order for
them to order more lamps so it's really
not just about somebody resourceful and
somebody less resourceful it's about
sort of sharing a vision
obviously distributing the the resources
accordingly but the core of this is a
lot of the things that I spoke about in
the other project this is a work of art
that then has wandered outside and
sometimes for a lot of people it doesn't
necessarily mean or doesn't necessarily
have to be a work of artists but it's
never just functional it's never not
it's never just something functional oh
I need light if it doesn't touch you
emotionally if you don't feel like
you're holding hands with the Sun you
won't buy it you're not gonna convince
somebody to buy a back a woman's back
your goods just confirm that if it's
just to carry your stuff around in it
right if that was it we wouldn't have
all these incredible companies now with
you know all these brands and so on if
it was all about functionality this is
the same thing if it doesn't inspire
people so a young mother taking her two
kids to school walking out in the
morning chatting this lamp around her
neck and the woman next door says oh my
God look at you you look at you you have
to wear this because you don't have
energy oh you are you are victim owner
you're a victim now the woman who takes
her kids to school and they make their
homework with this in the evening that
woman needs to say oh look at me and the
woman next door has to say how amazing
why don't I have one of these this is
cool so there's a lot of stories in this
but we are trying to address the
language in the same way we would do
here that this is about desire
aspiration inspiration it's about
creativity and self confidence and this
is I think where you know engineering
and creativity can work together and of
course
it amount of the success of of MIT has
been its ability has been it's in its
ability to to lean out into other fields
and I would encourage on the sort of
occasion of today and in the spirit of
the McDermott I would encourage this to
continue to take into your heart the
potential of working together with it
let's just say the cultural sector into
the arts into the dancers into the
people who are slow into the people who
are fast into the writers and theatres
and ballets and music and so on and I
think this is the way to the future as I
said in the beginning the models through
which we are going to create chains of
course some engineering is needed I give
you that following but touching people
takes something more than engineering
touching people alone won't do it also
so the coming together between you know
the thinking and the doing thinking
being engineering and the doing being
engineering the thinking being also art
and so on this is I think one of the
solutions in which we can create a lot
of change
I thank you so much for coming here we
have a few questions
we have some time for questions and
comments and I believe we have some
microphones so we'll pass those out in
anyone want to go first yes hi this is
really loud
this might be kind of a broad question
but what would your advice be to a
younger artist to aspires to your level
of greatness I think well the I so to my
participant in the school I always said
it's a matter of life and death if they
within the questions they're asking can
sense the urgency maybe it's not the
right question and the urgency can hide
itself in very obscure ways but it's
really important to sort of let's say
sort of focus on why before you focus on
how so that appears that how do I this
how do I that and so on but the question
why and it's a much more difficult
question to ask you know is this really
necessary why is this necessary
especially if you're an artist where you
seem to be doing a lot of not so
necessary stuff you have to still find a
little thing thin string might it may be
goes down to a hand sketch like the
little bit of hand dancing on a piece of
paper maybe that's enough
why I don't mean the rationale big
justifying why just the kind of
confidence oh my god I thought something
now it's on the paper it's amazing but
you have to have the confidence in the
worthwhile and that does take some
stamina as we all know it's very
difficult to make a little tough doodle
on a napkin I mean to make one that
actually matters is very difficult
thank you very much this is
extraordinary I don't know how much time
you have here in Boston or the area but
if you haven't I would hoped you'd have
a chance to visit artists for Humanity
in South Boston because what you were
describing this last project to me so
encompasses what is going on at afh
thank you yes it's it's I could not
agree more I'm not I've been coming to
Boston actually my first one-person show
I should have said that right away was
that the in America were first
one-person show in America but at the
ICN in Boston and with with jill and
jessa Malkin and and soon after the
first retro body colony was not actually
the survey show of my work was in San
Francisco that traveled and it just I
also said because Madeleine who did that
show you mentally the beginnings
actually here aren't you madly
oh hi my Linda
I love know so but yeah so you're
totally right and no I am NOT here for
long enough
yes thank you was your work in any way
inspired by christos work I like the
idea that crystal could create this kind
of public you know attention wrapping
their work I stark was just you know
around the time where I was going to
Berlin a lot second week in my into my
art school I started in October 2000 in
89 end of October two weeks into art
school the wall in Berlin came down and
I drove down and so on so and then you
know the Chris to the wrapping of the
Reichstag was very important for me I
was actually more into the
dematerialization team from the West
Coast Robert Irvine loved Robert Irwin
Day and James Terrell the people who
somehow suggested that psychology
contemplated contemplative ideas space
you know if the D materializing art
could be of some importance later I
became more interested in the East Coast
people like Jordan to be kind of more so
structurally organized people crystal
kind of came later on I was more like
gosvamis o'clock or more Robert Morris
oh hi I'm very interested in the
participatory part of your work and how
the spectator becomes a participant for
example on the weather project so I'm
wondering to what extent do you plan for
a particular reaction and to what extent
is it a surprise
well I coming coming at you know being
going to art school in the late 80s
early 90s but there was very rewarding
for me as a certain regime of object
hood kind of ended the 80s candid there
was some focus back on kind of more
political or activists ik ideas but you
know a few like amazing artists like
Felix gonzalez-torres a Katie Nolan came
out of America like unbelievable
interesting times and for me it was a
moment where the avant-garde idea of
freedom which was so important for art
like that created the mud modernism the
idea was somehow suddenly engaging again
with responsibilities then we had
phenomenology in the 90s we had Toulouse
and you know people who were thinking
about the sharing the co-producing the
co-authoring the negotiations the fact
that reality was to some extent relative
who knew Latour came along with
introduced soft sciences or social
sciences and so and you know I was
really just stepping stones through all
those people I sound like sounds I I
don't you know as an artist you can just
hop through all of that and enjoy so
just read the best parts but but the
point here is that combining this idea
of freedom and the responsibility that
comes with that and then the idea of
responsibility very much is about
freedom is always about me me me me I
want to be free there's a degree of you
know sometimes you can be so avant-garde
that you kind of disconnect you become
so much about your own the conditions of
your own the freedom of speech almost so
I think my generation and I'm lucky to
be a part of that generation this sense
of responsibility introduced the notion
well you cannot be responsible if you're
only one person like with freedom you
have to be at least two people and
better even more
this is where the door sort of open to
the kind of idea of the participatory
productivity I would almost call it
considering the the visitor the museum
being you know almost as important as
the artist being an artist I was so just
keep it but and of course and now the
truth is museum thinks that they are the
most of us so they can't miss they miss
the whole whole thing but the point but
by all means if there would be no
artists there would be no machines it's
just so make that but then you have the
visitors probably also that would be
with our visitor who know so I think the
participatory also have to do with
showing that trust in people being able
to use abstraction for something
valuable is so important and it just
doesn't happen yeah wish you look if you
look at the ways that that I said they
ever say look at the internet now I had
this amazing meeting with all these so
talented people up at the Media Lab
several groups and so now I'm very
uncertain whether what I say is now
actually true but know this the tendency
is of course people they kind of just
consumed they don't produce and I will
learn today this is maybe not totally
true
but generally speaking I'm very
interested in handing over the trust to
the people that they feel that they can
actually produce realities so I was like
a reality machine but if you don't
participate in it it doesn't do it
doesn't do anything
um hi as a light artist do you feel a
sense of responsibility in promoting
solar power and energy efficiency in
your installations like as a sort of
role model for people and artists to
follow or do you do you choose that in
your work yeah it's for some extent I
have
yeah I'm not maybe the kind of typical
ecologically very correct artist I'm not
I'm not the worst yeah I think I to be
honest I have to a great extent become
involved with with being like you
suggest that well I better I better
start using LED bulbs in a sculpture
just somehow somehow it's also important
but I also have to say that looking at
you know a kundus what do you call it
content sentient lamp is not the right
word or solar in consider then if you
look at that it's just so much more
beautiful than a bloody LED so what do
you do if you want to address beauty but
then again these lovely LED companies
that keep sending me small samples and
say and the quality of the light
actually does get better a lot better
actually and now you know we have great
LED panels who are in you know like a
very very interesting but it's important
that it's just you know it's it's maybe
in an evolution it is not replacing
something else it's maybe something
which is just ending and then something
else is you know taking over and this is
so so in that sense yes I have started
becoming much more aware of it it took
me some time it take me some time this
is an LED and it's interesting you know
not a long time ago that was an
expensive LED now it's like now as this
is a quality LED and now it's how much
is it Fredrik 0.06 cent and it's a good
LED it's from there's no no every
services
I won't say it but it's reported so I
don't have to say but but this is the
price of an LED i remember in seventh no
I started school 70s there's this
amazing girl in the seventh grade I was
like first grade and she had this I
thought I should have said it at the
beginning she had this in credit
so I was very curious she had this
amazing calculator in her back I was
like that's not exactly in love with it
but I thought she was amazing and then
see then I looked at it and then it had
all these other you know it was brown
and gold and they had red digits I just
looked at that red color and it's so
funny because it was a Texas Instrument
and and and I was so excited to see
there was the numbers 1 to 9 and then
plus minus and then there's all the
other things mom could press on I was
like my god like all this earth like and
the red color of that light so I was at
the beginning I remember from very early
on being taken about the kind of the
quality of a offered experience of light
and this incredible girl and and you
know the engineering effort and it's
actually the first time I came across
and I really remember it very clearly
the Texas since but do you remember they
were kind of gold and brown it's kind of
funny
all right how collaborative is your
studio say that again
how collaborative is your studio it's a
I rely a lot on the talent at the studio
there's a lot of things that I've done
it all and then at some point in the
process I say too much logistics I want
to only do the creative stuff then you
ask somebody do it then it turns out
they do it much better than some a
little bit better then and I did and and
it just it just so it turns out that
actually it's it has become it's become
a much better run place after other
people assisted and took over and so on
and now of course where's where's this
lessor I would like to think that I'm
the artist
and the one who makes the call and this
means that I start an idea I start a
process very often it's fed by an ill
and they already existing but I start
something then we go we branch into five
options and we work in five options
digitally modules build it make it
testing testing with water under water
with light or something and then say or
the three options there they are
impossible I don't like that why don't
we take these two options then everybody
works with these two options and then we
build a model of the space one-to-one we
take the space from the museum it
literally moves it to Berlin then we
build it up and then there's two two
teams almost you know and and then I I'm
involved then we bring in theory
criticizing did somebody do something
similar whatever they think so 200 years
ago there's a kind of a symphony about
that particular problem which you would
listen to that why we do it so and then
a lot of ideas are coming together so
it's a little bit difficult to say where
it's exact the exact bartenbach sort of
boundaries but we are you know I hope we
all agree that I'm the one who makes
but but I have on the other side I've
always always had an open-door policy
because there is a lot of artists and
and and bless them for that who have
closed and mystified the artists to do
and and kept you know in order to
prevent and I would argue for market
reasons the kind of this idea of you
know sort of so keeping secret that so
there's like a painter who only makes
painting it has like ninety assistants
painting I said I kind of like yeah sort
of obviously yes to keep it close
because they were so not so good for his
market you could say I don't think of
that being a problem I think why don't
everybody just come and look for
themselves and I don't mean that
literally
but the truth but the principle is
that's why I've done a number of works
addressing the studio as laboratory as a
sort of producer I worked with the idea
of mixing the museum the studio the
residency the school was in my studio
exactly to kind of show the students
well let's just be pragmatic let's be mi
cheese about it and sort of think of it
as a lab obviously one would think that
there is a degree of leadership at MIT
as well sort of pushing the things in
the right direction and I think of my
studio like that and I have no problem
suggesting that art can to a great
extent be a you know a collaborative
effort like that
yeah that's a good question I think that
I think the I think that they so for me
it doesn't really ever end and it's not
like the work before was somehow our
less important than the actual work and
and now with the weather project it did
end and it did close
I remember they wanted to prolong it we
did one time for long and then they were
so successful they said why don't we run
it for another six weeks and then I said
no let's close it it's like so
successful why not close it now but it
did continue it turned out I was with
her I was with a professor today about
the Media Lab what was his name Lila the
guy who had the photo of the weather
project on his book what William rikuo
from CMS so he had a book with the son
of still around do you know what I mean
if the weather project was on the cover
of his book and yes it had a so funny he
actually had asked for permission but
it's an old book and and and in a way
these projects I look at them more as
kind of cause and effect so you do
something that sets some motion into
action and eventually something dies out
and something still moves so the project
isn't really over in that sense it was
not about the actual shape of the
project it was about the the what I
shouldn't say science but it was about
the kind of material that it negotiated
that material is still around the work
is still producing reality as a in this
case it's a social dialogue it is
hopefully being considered as a as a
work that is worth bringing up in in
different discussions I have yeah
maybe this gentleman there dissenters
had his hand up
I saw the weather project in London and
was impressed but I may be the only
other person here with solar so here's
some light from Cambridge from yesterday
great great right so that's that's about
10 years old off-the-shelf equipment
that I've been using for my bike lights
every day since then and it's amazing to
me that I'm the only person that I see
walking around MIT with something like
that or Cambridge or Boston the very few
people who take care of that in the
little Sun one of the things that I find
about solar is that it's currency and
local production in the terms of Gandhi
and economics why does she local
production but light is one currency
electricity which is what runs the light
also can run AAA batteries which are the
most used batteries in the world and
charge cell phones and there's seven
billion cell phones now in the world for
seven and a half billion people and I'm
wondering if you're extending your idea
from light to the currency of
electricity and the economics of a solar
Swadeshi yes it's a it's a good question
and the thing the thing is I've been
stepping through departments here and
I've been meeting definitely 20 people
who are working with solar and small
solar objects in the micro solar systems
and so on so there's like so solar ever
if you ask me there's like solar
everywhere but yes I know Frederic tells
me not to be talking about it but we are
this summer actually bringing out the
little Sun mobile charger sort of a very
beautiful exactly because of the same
thing we are working very hard on our
retail and business model and delivery
systems and the whole economic sort of
so-called Bo P economic and we had great
sloan input also on on some ideas on
that so I didn't say that before you
should really not hesitate to go to
Leyland come and there's a few
introductions some are more technically
if you're more in the kind of nerdy area
and some are more emotional if you're
more
creative but what I'm actually asking us
see it's not quite gonna do it you have
to learn you know there's all that like
it's ended interest Instagram Azure all
that's social media stuff which we live
off no so this is how people actually
learn about the story and bring about
and we have we have brought and I didn't
bring that number we we we have produced
two hundred and fifty thousand lamps one
about 180 we have already delivered 30
percent one-third has been delivered in
off-grid so it's a great equation this
means we have in the tool one and a half
year almost two years we have actually
had a robust curve this is why I have to
tell you need it's not enough for me to
toggle you need to go and then say you
know send it to or all that send it to a
friend and like it and Facebook and and
all of that
you simply this has been what has been
driving us so the online communities the
sharing the stories the uploading images
has been one of the drivers in the
success which we also talked about here
at MIT because there's so much talent in
that field as well so it's very
interesting it's it's not just
engineering and art it's also
communication retail policy making new
economies economically model micro
distribution last mile succeed successes
and so on I have rarely learned it's
like being a young artistic and you
lunch I have learned so much from from
this project I will also learn to be
humble that's very very new for me I
mean this in the broader sense possible
but to you what is the place of
spectacle when you're making art I'm so
they say that again for you what is the
place of spectacle when you're making
art or thinking about art so I work a
lot with the sort of experience of
potential and of course I would want
people to take a groundbreaking
experience and that could be a sort of
micro gonna say nano groundbreaking
experience or like a really
groundbreaking sense of the big sort of
pathetic groundbreaking several spirits
but but I'm also quite aware of there is
economy which is very active within the
notion of the spectacle and that economy
has brought about the experience
industry or experience economy and of
course the kind of shallow or hollowness
of the spectacle with regards to
facilitating a profitable idea of what
how to drive the experience economy so
I'm sometimes frankly speaking torn
between you know how can I suggest that
what I do is not just hollow but how do
you know in the world today it's also
hard to see and you know look at
something I go like well does this
person actually really mean it or I
suggest some kind of lalala and and it's
it's difficult and it's getting
difficult especially as the museums and
the institutions that facilitate are
they are forced in our society into
systems where they need to quantify
their successes by virtue of telling the
politicians so and so many numbers so
and so much success criteria that you
can actually measure is how we run the
museum and of course then the artists
ago like what about if my show was not
you know a sort of high high hitter in
numbers does that mean it wasn't good at
so of course we are seeing situations
where the spectacle is kind of becoming
an ambiguous situation where a museum is
kind of forced into a situation where
whether if we are going to keep up the
fund and we have to deliver something
like that and then they call me right
and then I have to then I have to have
that bit of sort of sort of kind of
dancing with the museum about well
instead of talking about how we should
talk about why and that takes a little
time sometimes because once you are into
the discussion of why normally you can
nail the museum down to the values that
they used when they started and this is
I think where it gets interesting and
then you can bring museums into the sort
of risk zone and then you obviously need
to not just call the fire department say
oh it's gonna be okay just let's do it
you it's gonna be okay you also call the
police and say why don't we take that
risk
by God I forgot it's about art anyway
it's not about politicians and so on and
sadly this is getting increasingly
difficult
I have to say museums being so forced
into the traditional commerce the
community commodification of our senses
the experience economy blah blah so so
there's a very important area there and
we also have to say in America the
private sector is the one that is
supporting the museums we need the
private sector to be very risk oriented
and as we know the private sector is not
necessarily the most risk oriented
people and the render by all means the
public sector is not risk you're in
today as well as well so it's a very
interesting discussion how do we
facilitate a space in which an
experience can be about the experience
and not about all that other stuff thank
you so much
just the word the Council for the Arts
at MIT has demonstrated again impeccable
taste in selecting olefin and I've got
to say if Frederick autoscent is very
MIT sir
so are you delighted you're here